so at first when Fox News hosts Shepard Smith
criticized Trump here or there, or call out
some obvious problems,
why?
It was sort of a curiosity and it's now happening
in such a way that I'm increasingly convinced
that this is actually part of a crafted strategy
around Shepherd Smith.
I've got a clip for you here.
We're Shep Smith.
Straight up calls Donald Trump's hurricane,
hurricane Dorian sharpie fiasco.
Fake news defined, and we have to really understand
this for what it is.
But first, let's look at the clip.
Remember, this is on right wing Fox News.
Some
things in Trump.
Landia are inexplicably this week's edition,
the president's ongoing claim that Alabama
was at risk from Hurricane Dorian.
It wasn't.
Maybe he got some bad info from somebody.
Maybe he made a mistake.
Maybe he was confused.
We don't know.
But he was wrong.
And since for days and days he's been insisting
with fake visual aids in hand that he was
right
and then calling it what it is.
Fake news defined.
Why would the president of the United States
do this?
He decries fake news that isn't and disseminates
fake news that is thick.
China pays the tariffs.
The wall is going up.
Historic inauguration crowds.
Russia probe is a witch hunt.
You need an ID to buy cereal.
Noise from windmills causes cancer.
It's endless.
And now the Sharpie map that hurricanes Alabama,
a reporter asked him about it.
[inaudible] or Sharky.
I don't know.
He doesn't know, but he won't let it go.
Yesterday he brought out another map and a
statement that reads.
This was the originally projected path of
the hurricane in its early stages.
As you can see, almost all models predicted
it would go through Florida and hitting Georgia
and Alabama.
I except the fake news.
Apologies.
This is where one where he could apologize
and just move on.
That map was from the day hurricane became
a hurricane eight days ago, August the 28th.
It was four days old at the precise time.
He said Alabama would likely be hit harder
than anticipated and by then it was fake news
defined on a very serious subject.
This is not Shep Smith stepping out of line
with a disdain against his bosses at Fox News.
It's abundantly clear that this is happening
with Fox News, his executives, uh, approving
at least implicitly, and I've been telling
you this for nearly two years at this point,
I get emails from people.
How is shep getting away with this?
Isn't shep potentially going to get fired?
We need to reset our analysis of how corporate
media works.
Fox News wants to make money above all else.
They've decided to do this with right-wing
editorial positions in general.
They're not married to Trump, but they are
right wing.
But they also benefit from having some ideological
cover, especially when it seems that they
may break with the Trump train.
So what you need to understand is that Shep
Smith provides ideological cover to Fox News
with safe calculated dissent from the, everything
Trump says is gospel perspective, which you
see with Sean Hannity and Jeanine Pirro and
Laura Ingram and many others.
Shep Smith isn't going to do anything that
would really damage Fox News.
Like for example, chef's not going to call
out the lack of regulation that allows corporate
media outlets to become so big and monopolistic
and be so intertwined with government and
Internet service providers and ultimately
foment narratives that don't challenge their
privileged status as legacy elite corporate
media.
He's never going to do that.
Trump will tell a thousand lies and every
once in a while shep will call one or two
of them out for being lies.
It will get some people on the left to reconsider
whether Fox News is as bad as we think it
is.
It'll get some discussion about what's going
on on Fox News.
It will get some right-wingers saying homophobic
things about Shepherd Smith in calling for
his firing.
Yes.
But the biggest thing that this does is create
some deniability for Fox News to say, look,
we don't always carry water for Trump.
We don't always defend everything a republican
does.
So our analysis must account for the end game
in the short run at the micro level.
It's good to expose some Trumpists watching
Fox two a tiny dose of reality in the big
picture.
Shep Smith on Fox News, occasionally telling
some uncontroversial truth, uncontroversial
to us that is is not going to change the role
that Fox News in the corporate media space
plays.
And that's the analysis that I've been making
for a long time.
To the extent that someone's echo chamber
might be pierced by Shep, great.
Maybe it'll bring a little small electoral
advantage in 2020 if enough Trumpists have
their echo chamber pierced by chef Smith,
but it does nothing to achieve the wholesale
reform goals and d corporatization and d propaganda's
creation of corporate profit driven media
that we've been talking about.
And it's really important merely to acknowledge
what's happening with Shep for what it is
and not go beyond that because it simply doesn't
make sense and it's not actually born out
by the facts